The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So far in our
discussion of probability,
we've focused our attention
on the probability
that some kind of event
occurs-- the probability you
win the Monty Hall game,
the probability that you get
a heads when you flip a
coin, the probability we all
have different birthdays in
the room-- that kind of thing.
In each case, the event
happens or it doesn't.
It's a zero-one kind of thing.
For the rest of
the course, we're
going to start talking about
more complicated situations.
Instead of talking
about zero-one events,
like winning or
losing, we're going
to start talking about
how much you win.
Instead of talking
about whether or not
you get a heads in
a coin flip, we're
going to talk about
flipping lots of coins
and asking how many
heads did you get?
Now, this involves the
notion of a random variable
to count how much or how
many in a random situation.
And actually, the
name is sort of weird.
It's not a variable at all.
In fact, a random variable
is a function from the sample
space to the real numbers.
See random variable R is a
function R from the sample
space to the reals.
So this is the random
variable, and we'll often
denote that by rv.
This is the sample space
of all possible outcomes.
And this is just the reals.
All right, so in other
words, a random variable
is just a way of
assigning a real number
to each possible outcome.
For example, say that
we toss three coins.
We could let R equal the number
of heads among the three coins.
And R is thus a random variable.
For example, for the outcome
where the first coin is heads,
the second is tails,
and the third is heads,
R would be the real
number 2, indicating I
got two heads in that outcome.
We could also define another
value called M, which we'll say
is 1 if all three coins match,
if they're all the same,
and 0 otherwise, if
they're not all the same.
For example, M on the outcome
heads, heads, tails is 0.
M on the outcome
tails, tails, tails
would be 1, because
they all are the same.
Is M a random variable?
Yeah, it assigns a value, a
real number, to every outcome.
And that value is
either 0 or 1, depending
on if all the coins match.
In fact, it's a very special
kind of random variable
that's called an indicator
random variable, also
known as Bernoulli or
characteristic random variable,
because it's zero-one.
An indicator also
known as a Bernoulli
or characteristic
random variable,
is a random variable whose
range or possible values
is just 0 and 1.
So it's a random variable
where the real numbers
are 0, 1 that you assign
to every sample point.
And it's called a characteristic
or indicator random variable
because it indicates
which sample points have
a certain property.
In this case, all the
coins were the same.
Or it indicates
that a sample point
has a certain
characteristic, which
is why it's called a
characteristic random variable.
And we're going to
be talking a lot
about these kinds
of random variables
over the next couple of weeks.
Now, in general, a random
variable is equivalent to,
or it can define a partition
on the sample space.
For an indicator
random variable,
it defines a partition
with two blocks.
For example, say we look at the
sample space with three coin
tosses there.
There's eight outcomes.
There's heads, heads,
heads; heads, tails, heads;
heads, heads, tails;
tail, heads, heads;
and the reverse of those.
This is the sample space
when I toss three coins.
There's eight possible outcomes.
The random variable M
defines this partition.
Up top, you have M equals 1, and
down below you have M equals 0.
Because these are the outcomes
where all the coins match.
These are the ones that don't.
The random variable R defines
a different partition.
In that case, the
partition has four blocks.
Here is R equals 0, no heads.
This is R equals 1, to one head.
R equals 2, and R equals 3.
So a random variable just sort
of organizes your sample space,
partitions it into
blocks, defined
by all the elements
in the block,
the outcomes in the
block have the same value
for the random variable.
And, in fact, every
block is really an event.
In particular, we
can say that, if you
look at the outcomes for
which the random variable
on that outcome
equals some value x,
this is simply the
event that R equals x.
The random variable is x.
And, of course, an event is just
a subset of the sample space.
It's a collection of outcomes
that define the event.
And since we know we could talk
about probabilities of events,
we can now say things like this.
We can say the probability
that a random variable equals
x is simply the probability
of that event happening, which
is the sum over all outcomes
for which the random variable
equals x for that outcome,
summing its probability.
So the probability that the
random variable equals a value
is the sum of the probabilities
of the sample points
for which R has that value.
All right, this is all
really basic stuff,
but important to get down.
So, for example,
what's the probability
that R equals 2 in our
case with the three coins?
You flip three coins-- let's say
the coins are fair and mutually
independent.
We probably need to know that.
What is the
probability R equals 2?
AUDIENCE: 3/8?
PROFESSOR: 3/8, because you've
got three outcomes, each
with a probability 1/8.
All right, so by
this definition, that
would be the same as the
probability of heads, heads,
tails; heads, tails,
heads; tails, heads,
heads; that's 3/8.
What's the probability
that M equals 1?
M is 1 if all the coins match.
1/4 because you've got two
cases there-- heads, heads,
heads-- whoops--
or tails, tails,
tails; and that's 2/8, or 1/4.
Now we can also talk
about the probability
that a random variable
is in some range.
For example, I could ask,
what's the probability
that R is at least 2?
All right, that would mean the
sum i equals 2 to infinity,
the probability R equals i.
And what is that?
What's the probability?
R is at least 2.
1/2.
It's the probability
that R equals 2,
plus the probability
that R equals 3.
There's four outcomes there,
each with 1/8, so that's 1/2.
And finally, we can talk
about the probability
that R is in some set of values.
So we could say, for
example, for any subset
of the real numbers, we
define the probability
that R attains a value
in that set is simply
the sum over all possible
values in the set,
that the probability
R equals that value.
So we could ask, what's the
probability that, say, we
take A being the set 1, 3.
I could ask for
the probability R
is A when it's 1, 3, which is
the same as the probability
R is odd.
Because Our could
only be 0, 1, 2, or 3.
What's the probability R
is odd in this example?
Flip three coins, we're
asking the probability
you get an odd number of
heads-- one or three heads.
1/2.
Again, you've got four sample
points-- here and there.
So that's 1/2.
All right, any questions
about the definition?
All right, now, we're only
going to worry about the case
when random variables
are discrete.
Namely, there's a
finite number of values.
If you have continuous random
variables, which they'll
deal with in other
courses, instead
of doing sums and
stuff like that,
you're working with integrals.
But for this course, it's
going to be all countable sets,
and usually often finite sets.
Now, conditional probability
carries over very nicely
to random variables as well.
For example, we could
write down the probability
that R equals 2 given that M
equals 1, where R and M are
the same random variables
we've been looking at when
you flip the three coins.
What is that probability?
0, the probability of getting
exactly two heads when they're
all the same, can't happen.
It's 0.
You can either have
three heads or no heads.
So that's 0.
The notion of independence
also carries over
to random variables,
but you've got
to be a little careful here.
Two random variables,
R1 and R2, are
said to be independent if-- and
this is a little complicated--
for all possible
values, x1 and x2
in the real numbers, the
probability that R1 is x1,
given that R2 is x2, is the
same as the probability of R1
equals x1 not knowing
anything about R2.
Or there's a special case
when this can't happen.
Namely, the probability
that R2 equals x2 is 0.
So, for two random
variables to be independent,
it needs to be the case that,
no matter what happens out here
with R2, and whatever
you know about it,
it can't influence
the probability for R1
to equal anything.
So no value of R2
influences any value of R1.
So it's the strongest possible
thing with independence
for it to apply to
random variables.
And there's an
equivalent definition,
and we're going to use these
interchangeably, just as there
were two definitions for
independence of events,
there's the product for them.
So the equivalent
definitions says
for all x1 and x2 in the
real numbers, the probability
that R1 equals x1 and
R2 equals x2 is simply
the product of
those probabilities.
Probability R1 equals x1 times
the probability R2 equals x2.
And you don't have to
worry about that case
where R2 being x2 is 0.
So we can use both of those
as definitions of independence
of random variables.
All right, so let's
see an example.
We've got R and M. We've talked
about two random variables.
Are they independent
random variables?
M is the indicated
random variable
for all the coins matching.
R is the random variable
that tells us how many heads
there were in three coins.
Are they independent?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No, why not?
AUDIENCE: Because information
with what one is narrows down
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's true.
Information about
what one value is
influences the probability
that the other guy
has a certain value.
In particular, we can
find a case of x1 and x2
where this fails.
One case would be
the probability
of what we've already done,
that R equals 2 and M equals 1.
What was this probability?
0.
If everything matches,
you can't have two heads.
That's 0.
That does not equal
the probability
of two heads times the
probability they all match.
Because this probability,
two heads is 3/8,
probability they
all match is 1/4.
And 3/8 times a 1/4 is not 0.
So R and M are not independent.
OK, now in general to
show two random variables
are not independent,
all you gotta
do is find one pair of [? out ?]
values for which there's
dependence.
To show their
independent, you've
got to deal with all
possible pairs of values.
So it's harder show
independence in general.
All right, let's
do another example,
get a little practice with this.
Say we have two fair independent
six-sided die, normal dice.
And the outcome of
the first one is D1,
and the outcome of
the second roll is D2.
And by independent, I mean here
that knowing any information
about what the second
die is does not
give you any change
in your probability
that the first
die has any value.
And now we define
another value, S,
to be D1 plus D2,
the sum of the dice.
Is S a random variable?
Yeah, for any outcome-- an
outcome being a pair of dice
values-- it maps that
outcome to a real number,
a number between 2 and 12, OK?
Let's do another one.
Let's let T be 1 if S is 7,
namely the sum of the dice
is 7, and 0 otherwise.
T is also a random variable.
In fact, what kind is it?
Yeah, indicator,
characteristic, whatever.
It's telling you if the sum
of the dice is 7 or not.
All right, now, there's
four random variables here.
Each die, which we
already have told you,
we're assuming are independent.
The sum and the indicator
if the sum is 7.
All right, what about
these two values?
Are D1, the first die,
and the sum independent?
AUDIENCE: No?
No?
PROFESSOR: No,
intuitively they're not.
Because if I know something
about the first die,
I probably know
something about the sum.
Now to really nail
that down, you've
got to give me a
value for this, which
influences the probability
that obtains some value, right?
That's how you would convince
me that, in fact, they're
dependent.
Can anybody give
me a value for this
that changes the probability
this equals something?
AUDIENCE: Guess?
If it's like 1, then
[INAUDIBLE] has to be 6.
PROFESSOR: If this is
1, what value of this
could be influenced?
AUDIENCE: You know that in order
for-- the only set of values
S can take now, it can only
be from 1 to-- from 2 to 7.
PROFESSOR: From 2 to 7.
In particular now,
this can't be 12.
So what I could do is say
the probability that S
equals 12 and the first die
was 1, what's that probability?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0.
And that does not
equal the probability
S is 12 times the probability
the first die was 1.
Or we could plug it into
the other definition.
The probability that S equals
12 given the first die is 1
is not equal to the
probability S equals 12.
And, in fact, probability
the first die is 1 is not 0.
So either definition,
of course, works
to show that they are dependent.
So S and D1 are dependent.
All you need is
one possible pair
of values to show dependence.
That's usually easy to do.
All right, what about
D1, the first die, and T,
the indicator for getting a 7?
Are D1 and T independent
random variables?
All right, somebody's
shaking their head no.
They seem to be dependent
because knowing the first die
seems like it should tell you
something about the probability
of getting a 7 for the sum.
That's a good first intuition.
In fact, you always
want to assume
things are dependent unless you
convince yourself otherwise.
It's always a good rule.
Now, in fact, in this
case, it is independent.
The probability of getting
a 7 is not, it turns out,
influenced by the first die.
Anything else would
be, but 7 is not.
Let's see why that is.
And to do that, we'd
actually have to check,
I think, 12 cases, all
possible values for D1 and T,
but you'll get the
idea pretty quick.
The probability that T
equals 1, namely you got a 7,
given that D1 equals 1.
What's that?
The probability of getting 7
for the sum given your first die
is a 1, what's that probability?
AUDIENCE: 1/6?
PROFESSOR: 1/6, because the
second one better be a 6.
All right, and what's the
probability T equals 1?
What's the probability
of rolling a 7?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: 6/36.
PROFESSOR: 6/36.
There's six ways to do it.
1 and 6, 2 and 5, 3 and 4, 4
and 3, 5 and 2, and 6 and 1,
out of 36 possibilities
equally likely.
So that worked here.
Now probability of getting
a 7 given the second
die-- sorry-- the
first die is a 2.
What's that?
Probability of getting a 7 given
that your first die is a 2.
1/6, because you've got to
have the second die be a 5,
and that happens 1/6.
And that equals the right thing.
In fact, I can
keep on going here.
Probability T equals 1,
given D1 is anything, 6.
Well, for every
value of D1, there's
exactly one value of
D2 that adds to a 7.
So it's still 1/6, which is
the probability of getting
the 7 in the first place.
Now we've also got to check
the probability T equals 0,
given all these cases for D1.
D1 equals 1.
What's this?
The probability of not getting
a 7 given the first die is a 1.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: 5/6.
PROFESSOR: 5/6, it's the
opposite of this case.
They pair up.
That's got to be 5/6,
and that is, of course,
the probability of T equals 0.
And the same is true for
all the other five cases.
The probability T equals
0 given any value of D
is 5/6, which equals, the
probability T equals 0.
So we check all
possible values of T1
and all possible ways of
D1, and lo and behold,
it works every time.
So knowing the
first die does not
change the probability
of getting a 7.
Would it change the
probability of getting a 6?
Yeah, because if the
first die were a 6,
you know you're going
to get more than a 6.
So it just holds
true because I picked
it to be an indicator for 7.
Any questions about that?
So if you're ever asked to
show things are independent,
you've got to go
through all the cases.
If you're asked to
show their dependent,
just find one case that
blows it up, and you're done.
OK, you can also talk
about independence
for many random variables.
And you have a notion
of mutual independence.
And this is a little hairy.
It's a natural thing.
R1, R2, up to Rn are mutually
independent if for all
the values of all the random
variables, so x1, x2, xn.
And we're going to give the
product form, because it's
the simpler way to do it here.
The probability that R1 is
x1, and R2 is x2, and Rn is xn
equals the product of the
individual probabilities.
It's the natural generalization
for two variables.
And there's also
the equivalent form
in conditional probabilities,
but that's a little harrier
to write down, and we
generally don't work with that.
Any questions about
mutual independence?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So any subset what?
PROFESSOR: Yes, in
the conditional form
you check any subset,
here you don't have
to worry about the subsets.
You take any possible
value for all of them,
so there's no subset
notation in this version,
so you can do without it.
That would be
equivalent, there's
another form where you look
at all the possible subsets
as well, and
conditioning on that.
But this is good enough,
and this is probably
the simplest way to do
the mutual independence,
is like this.
So every variable
is included here.
And that will imply the
same thing for any subset.
You don't have to check
every subset here.
And then you could do
that by just summing
over Rn being everything,
and that cancels away
to get rid of items.
But you don't have
to worry about that.
OK, so we're going to
change gears a little bit
now, and talk about the
probability distribution
function, which is just
a way a sort of writing
down or characterizing the
probabilities associated
with each value being attained.
So given a random variable,
R, the probability
also known as the point,
distribution function,
also denoted pdf, probability
distribution function, for R
is, well, it's very simple.
It's just the function
f of x, which equals
the probability that R is x.
Very simple.
But now we're characterizing
it as a function.
And there's also a notion of
the cumulative distribution
function, which is going to
be the probability that R
is less than or equal to x.
Let's write that down.
The cumulative
distribution function F
for random variable
R is simply f
of x is the probability that
R is at most x, which is just
the sum over all y
less than or equal to x
the probability R equals y.
So the distribution functions
characterize the probability
a random variable
takes on any value,
and there's certain common ones
that just come up all the time.
And so people have
done a lot of analysis
about them because they
occur so frequently.
And we're going to talk
about three of them today.
The first is really
simple, and that
is the Bernoulli
random variable,
or indicator random variable.
All right, so for an indicator
random variable, f 0 is p,
and f 1 is 1 minus p, for sum p.
The probability could be half,
if you're flipping a coin.
The probability of heads could
be a half, probability of tails
would be a half.
It's just two values, 0 and 1.
And then the cumulative
function is very simple.
F 0 is p, big F of 1 is 1.
So that is about as simple
of functions as you can get.
The next simplest,
and also very common,
is called a uniform
random variable.
Let's define that.
For a uniform random
variable-- and we
have to define what
it's defined on--
on say the integers from 1 to n,
every value is equally likely.
All the integers from 1 to n
are equally likely to occur.
And so in this case, n is a
parameter of the function.
fn of K is simply 1/n.
Each integer from 1 to
n is equally likely.
So it's 1 and n.
All right, what is the
cumulative distribution
function for this?
What is big F of n
of K for the uniform?
The probability that
the random variable
takes a value that's at most K?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Close, K/n.
And you could
think of K being 1.
You have a least the
1 over n probability.
So you have K chances.
It could be 1, 2, 3, 4 up
to K, each has a 1/n chance.
Because we've got,
the definition
is less than or
equal, not less than.
Uniform distributions
come up all the time,
rolling a fair die is uniform
on 1 through 6 for values.
If I pick a random student
in the class, the chance
I pick you is 1 in
the size of the class.
We have uniform sample spaces.
Each outcome occurs
equally likely.
All right, any
questions about uniform?
[INAUDIBLE]
OK, so while we're
talking about uniform,
I want to play a
game, whose optimal
strategy is going to
turn out to be related
to uniform distributions.
Now the game works as follows.
I'm going to have
two envelopes here.
And inside each envelope,
I've written a number.
And the number in
this case is a number
between 0 and 100 inclusive.
It's not a random number,
because I wrote it,
and maybe I'm not
such a nice guy.
I might have picked nasty
numbers to write here.
They are different, though.
The numbers are different
in the envelopes.
Now I'm going to pick a
volunteer from the class,
and their job is to pick
the envelope with the bigger
number.
And if they get the one
with the bigger number,
then they get one of
these guys for ice cream.
And if they don't get the
one with the bigger number,
they get the nerd
pride pocket protector.
Now, since you don't know
which number I put in which,
50-50 if you get the prize,
the $10 gift certificate.
So to give you a
little bit of an edge,
I'm going to let you
open one of the envelopes
and see what number's there.
Then you have to decide, do
you want the number you got,
or do you want the
other envelope?
OK?
Is the game clear,
what we're going to do?
OK, so need a couple
of volunteers.
We're going to do it twice.
All right, somebody way
in the back up there.
Any other volunteers?
All right, come on down.
Oh, you've already
played before.
(LAUGHTER) You already got.
Who hasn't played before, wants
to-- all right, come on up.
Now you want to be thinking
about, boy, is there a strategy
here?
Or is this just
dumb luck, 50-50?
OK, what's your name?
AUDIENCE: Sean.
PROFESSOR: Sean.
All right, I got
two envelopes, Sean.
They are numbers
between 0 and 100.
And you can pick one, and
we'll reveal the number,
and then you decide.
Do you want the number you got,
or do you want the other one?
The goal is to get
the bigger number.
So take one and open it.
What did you get?
AUDIENCE: 6.
He got
PROFESSOR: A 6.
The numbers go from 0 to 100.
What do you think
Sean should do?
AUDIENCE: Switch.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What do you
think you should do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: They've got
to check the other one.
PROFESSOR: No, no, you
can't look at the other one.
And unfortunately,
you're going to play
with different envelopes.
What should you do?
6, there's a lot of numbers
bigger than 6, Sean.
But they might not
be in that envelope.
Might be a 0 in that envelope.
AUDIENCE: That would suck.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'll stay.
PROFESSOR: You're
going to stay with 6?
AUDIENCE: Yup.
PROFESSOR: All
right, he picked 6.
What do you think
he should have done?
How many people think
he should have switched?
Ooh, Sean.
How many people
like Sean's choice?
Not so good.
All right, let's see if you won.
Here we go.
5.
Sean wins the ice cream.
Good work.
Now Sean, what was
your thinking here?
AUDIENCE: I was
thinking [INAUDIBLE]
in the other envelope,
knowing that 6 doesn't tell me
anything about what's
in the other one,
so my chances of
seeing [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Totally 50-50.
How many people
buy that argument?
It's 50-50.
He really has no idea what's
in the other envelope.
How many people think
there's a better way?
Not too many.
All right, we're
going to try it again.
Well done.
I've got different
envelopes here.
And tell me your name again?
AUDIENCE: Drew.
PROFESSOR: Drew, OK Drew.
Two envelopes.
Which one would
you like to open?
AUDIENCE: They're
both labeled B.
PROFESSOR: They're both labeled
B. That won't help you there.
All right, he's got one.
Let's see what you got.
92.
Oh my goodness, and
we've seen what 5 and 6.
What are you going to do?
92.
What should he do, guys?
AUDIENCE: Stay.
PROFESSOR: Stay.
Oh he's got a big number there.
You're going to switch?
You're giving up a 92?
Ooh, you're sure?
You don't want the 92?
How many people think
Drew is going to win?
AUDIENCE: He's trying to lose.
PROFESSOR: A couple people.
Let's see.
AUDIENCE: 91.
It's either 91 or 93.
PROFESSOR: 93, how did you
know there was a bigger number?
Wow, very good.
There you go.
What was your strategy?
AUDIENCE: I figured you'd
probably pick them within 1.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Actually, they're
both [INAUDIBLE] to 93.
Would you still switch?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Still switch.
Hmm.
All right, so is it 50-50 then?
Because you see a 92 a 93,
you're switching either way.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: 50-50.
All right, how many
people still like 50-50?
He can't beat 50-50 here.
Any ideas?
Can you beat 50-50?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I just pay
attention to your face.
PROFESSOR: I guess
I gave it away.
I think I've lost every bet
so far in the course here,
even on Monty Hall, every time.
So I guess I have a
tell or something here.
Now, in fact, you
can beat 50-50.
The information is helpful.
Now, just to be clear,
are these numbers
that I wrote down random?
No.
No, I'm trying
not to give away--
my ice cream bill is going
through the roof here.
I'm trying to make it hard.
They're very much not random.
There were two
smalls and two bigs.
What is random here?
AUDIENCE: Which
one he picked is.
PROFESSOR: Which one he saw,
that's 50-50, effectively.
So that's random there.
Now his strategy could also
be random, but it wasn't.
His strategy was, if
he sees a big number,
he's swapping, which is odd.
Most people see the big
number, they want to keep it.
You know, I'd have
done well today
if I had a really big number
and a really small number,
because then I would
have won both times.
OK, so to see why there might
be a winning strategy, or better
than 50-50, imagine
that I had been nice
and put a very small
number in one envelope
and a very big number
of the other envelope.
Say I had a 5 in one
and a 92 in the other.
Can you win then,
if you know that?
OK, how do you win if
you know there's one less
than 10 and one bigger than 90?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you get the
one less than 10, switch.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
and you're going
to win with what probability?
1.
It's a certainty.
All right, well, but
I'm not that nice, say.
Say, though, there
is a threshold
x, such that one of the
numbers is less than x,
and one is bigger than
x, and you know x.
Can you win now?
Say you know that one number
is less than 47 and 1/2,
and one is bigger
than 47 and 1/2.
Can you win?
Yeah, because if you get the
one less than 47 and 1/2,
you switch.
And otherwise you'll stay.
So again, you win
with certainty.
All right, that's good.
Is there always such an x?
You may not know it, but
is there always such an x?
Yeah, because the
numbers are different.
Just pick up a real
number in between them.
You know, with 92 and
93, there's 92 and 1/2,
is such an x.
Now the only problem
is you don't know it.
And there's no way to
figure it out that's
within the rules of the game.
Now in life, if you
don't know something,
and you can't figure it
out, what can you do?
AUDIENCE: Guess.
PROFESSOR: Guess it.
All right, now this turns out
to be a really good thing to do,
and especially good in a lot
of computer science situations.
If you don't know it,
and you can't know it,
well you could try to guess
and you might be right.
Now, if you guess x
and you are right,
what's your
probability of winning?
1.
If you don't guess x, what's
your probability of winning?
Say you guess wrong, but
you follow the rule that
if it's less than what
you guessed, you swap it,
otherwise you don't.
What's your probability
of winning that?
P?
Well, yeah, what's P?
It's a nice value of P.
You know, say you
guessed-- well,
say you weren't paying
attention and you guessed 200.
And your rule is, if you're
less than what you guessed,
you're less than 200,
you swap, which means
you're just going to swap.
And you started with a
random one, so what's
your chance of winning?
A half.
So if you guessed wrong,
you didn't lose anything.
You still win with
probability a half.
If you guessed right, you
win with probability 1,
and there's some chance
you guessed right,
so now you've got a
strategy that beats 50-50,
because you guessed.
OK, and this is a whole
field in computer science
where you get randomized
algorithms, where
this strategy depends on a
coin flip, on guessing a value.
And it leads to getting
potentially a better outcome.
All right, so let's
prove that now
and see what the probability
is of winning with the guess
strategy and what's
a good way to guess.
So we're going to first
formalize our random protocol.
All right, so if this
is the winning strategy,
well first the envelopes
contain y and z,
and they're in the
interval 0 to n.
And y is going to
be less than z.
That's how we're
going to define them.
Now you don't know
y and z, but y
is the smaller number in the
envelope, z is the larger.
And in our example, n was 100.
Now the player
chooses x randomly,
uniformly among all the
possible half integers.
So he might pick 1/2, he might
pick 1 and 1/2, 2 and 1/2,
all the way out to n minus 1/2.
You know, because if the
player picks anything else,
it's useless.
He won't have a chance to win.
But he might, in
the case of 5 and 6,
might have picked 5 and 1/2.
And we're going to make our
random guess be equally likely
among those n values, because
well he doesn't really
know what the numbers are
I put in the envelopes.
If he sees 6, he doesn't
know if it's 5 or it's 7, OK?
So that's why we're going to
pick them all equally likely
and it's uniform.
Now the player is hoping
that he picked a value that
splits y and z, OK?
Because then he's going to win.
If he picked an x between
the numbers in the envelopes,
and follows the swap, if he got
the small number less than x,
he's going to win, all right?
Then the player opens a
random envelope, 50-50,
to reveal a number r,
which is either y or z,
but the player doesn't
know which one.
So one of the numbers
gets revealed.
And then the last step
is the player swaps
if the number he revealed is
less than the guessed split
number.
That's the strategy,
and it's a strategy
that depends on a random
guess or a random number.
So let's figure
out the probability
of winning with that strategy.
And we're going to
use the tree method.
Well, the first branch
in the tree method
is whether or not--
where the guess wound up.
And there's three cases
for how the guess did.
You might have guessed
too low, in which case,
x is less than y,
and y is less than z.
You might have guessed
perfectly, in which case
x is between y and z,
equals not possible.
Or you might have
guessed too high,
in which case y is less
than z is less than x.
All right, so here's low,
here's high, and here's
an OK guess, a good guess.
Now what's the probability
you guessed low, that you
picked an x less than y?
y is integers, x is
the half integers.
What's the probability
to assign to that chance,
that you guessed low?
You could use the value
of y in your answer.
You don't know y, but we
can write it on the tree.
What if y was 1?
The smallest number
in the envelopes
is one, what's the probability
you guessed below 1?
Not quite 0, one of your
possible end guesses
would be too low,
namely, a half.
If the smallest number
y were 2, what's
the probability
you guess below 2?
2/n.
And in general, if y
is the smallest value,
you've got y possible
guesses that it
would be too low, namely all
the half integers less than y.
So the probability
you guess low is y/n,
because each one
is 1 in n chance.
And there's y that are too low.
What's the probability
your guess is good,
that you split y and z?
z minus y over n, because
they're-- between these
integers, z and y, there's
z minus y half integers.
Each could have been guessed
with probability 1/n.
And what's the probability
you guessed high?
n minus z over n,
because there's
n minus g half
integers between z
and n being the last possible
one, and minus the half there.
All right, so we've
got the first branch.
Now the next branch
is the revealed value.
Did you open the smaller
one or the larger one?
r equals y means you
opened the smaller one.
r equals z means you
saw the bigger one.
All right, if I've gone
down this branch where
I guessed too low, but
I don't know that, yet,
but say I've guessed
too low, what's
the probability I opened
the smaller envelope?
One half, because you're just
picking a random envelope
and opening up.
So these each happen
with probability a half.
And that's true no matter what.
They're all one half.
All right, well, now we
can compute the probability
of each outcome.
This is y/n times
1/2, is y over 2n.
This is y over 2n also.
This is z minus y over 2n.
z minus y over 2n.
n minus z over 2n.
All right, I got all
the sample points.
I got all the probabilities.
Let's figure out if you win now.
And to do that, the first
thing we have to figure out
is, do you swap?
Do you swap here?
Well, what happened?
I revealed y, which is
bigger than my split value
x, my guessed value.
And so I am guessing I've
got the biggest value.
So I don't swap.
So there's no swap.
What about here?
Do I swap here?
I open z, I saw z.
z is bigger than what I
think the midpoint is,
so I wouldn't swap.
I only guess if
the value I reveal
is less than my
guessed midpoint.
If I got a value I see
bigger than my midpoint,
I think I've got the big one.
So there's no swap.
What about here?
Do I swap here?
Yes, here I swap
because I open up
something that's less
than my guessed midpoint,
so I think I've got the small
one so I'm going to swap.
What about here?
Do I swap here?
No swap, because I
opened up something
that's bigger than midpoint.
What about here?
I swap.
And what about here?
Swap on both of them,
because both of them
are smaller than my
guessed midpoint.
All right, now let's figure
out if you won or you lost.
So here I did not swap and I
started with a smaller value.
So what happened?
Did I win or lose?
Lose.
I opened he smaller
value and did not swap.
What happened here?
I win.
I open the bigger
value and did not swap.
Here what happened?
Win, I opened the small value
when I swapped, that's a win.
Here?
I opened the big
value, did not swap.
It's a win.
Here I opened a small value
and swap, that's a win.
And here I opened a big value
and swap, that's a lose.
All right, now we can compute
the probability of winning.
The probability of a win is
the sum of these four sample
points-- y over 2n plus
z minus y over 2n plus
z minus y-- whoops-- over
2n plus n minus z over 2n.
That equals-- z cancels the
z, and a y cancels the y,
so I've got n, one left,
n left, one z left,
and one negative y left over 2n.
And I can simplify that.
N over 2n is 1/2, plus
now what's left over
is z minus y over 2n.
And we know the z and y are
different by at least 1.
So this is at least
1/2 plus 1 over 2n.
And so if n is 100, you've got
a 50 and 1/2% chance of winning.
If n is 10, the numbers
are from 0 to 10,
you've got at least
a 55% chance to win,
which is pretty high, OK?
Any questions here?
You see what's going on?
So here's the zone
where you guessed right.
You get the win either way.
Here you guess low, and it
doesn't make any difference.
You're 50-50.
You guessed high and
you're 50-50 again.
So guessing helps.
Any questions about that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So aren't you
assuming that-- because you say,
have a range, a greater
range of numbers,
that's there's a greater
chance that the number is
going fall in that range.
PROFESSOR: I was
the nasty guy here.
I picked z and y to be
consecutive numbers, which
minimized your chance of
doing well with this strategy.
AUDIENCE: Because it
seems like we don't know
anything about [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The
distribution of what?
AUDIENCE: Of possible
other numbers
in envelopes [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, you know
nothing about the distribution
because there is none.
There's no randomness there.
I picked worst
case numbers here.
AUDIENCE: But it's still
sort of like a [INAUDIBLE].
If it's 10, you still
have a better chance
to swap than if you
[INAUDIBLE] below that.
PROFESSOR: No.
No, any deterministic
strategy you pick,
if you don't guess
that random x,
you will not do
better than 50-50.
The only way you'd beat
50-50 is to, in your mind,
make a random number 13
and 1/2 and flip if you
see less than 13 and 1/2.
If you come in with
a strategy that hey,
10 is a small
number, out of 100,
and so I'm going to
swap if I see a 10,
well, no, because first it
could be-- I might have done
9 or 11, either one.
In fact, if I know
that's your strategy,
I'm going to make a 9.
And then you're
doomed in seeing a 10.
AUDIENCE: So is there a
best way to pick that?
PROFESSOR: Yes, I also
have an optimal strategy.
In fact, there's two
interesting things
about this game
which we won't prove.
The first thing we'll prove,
we will prove but it's true,
is this is the optimal
strategy for you.
And my optimal
strategy is to pick
a random value of y
between 0 and n minus 1,
and then to make z be one more.
And the way to think
about this, and there's
whole classes you can
take on game theory,
is that suppose I do
pick my guys randomly
by picking a random y
uniformly from 0 to n minus 1.
So my smaller number is
anything between 0 and 99,
equally likely, and then the
bigger number's just one more.
So if I picked 92
for the random one,
the next one's going to be 93.
If that's my strategy,
even if I tell you that,
you cannot do any better than
getting 1/2 plus 1 over 2n
probability of winning, no
matter what you do in the whole
world, OK?
And if you use
this strategy here,
no matter what I do, even
knowing that's your strategy,
I can't keep you from
getting this much.
It's called a minimax solution.
So my optimal strategy is to
pick uniformly in 0 to 99,
and the next one's one more.
Your optimal strategy is this.
Pick a number uniformly in
the half integers there,
and swap if you see
something smaller.
And there's no better strategy.
In fact, any
deterministic strategy,
you don't do better than 50-50.
The optimal strategies require
randomness for each of us.
OK, any more questions about
what happened here, this game?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
when you see
a small number you're going
to swap, does that just mean
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, basically,
yeah, that's what it means.
Effectively, that 50
is your random number.
If you think OK, if I see less
than 50, I'm going to swap,
bigger than 50 I don't.
Now you have to
decide what happens
at 50, if you saw exactly 50.
So you'd probably go in at
49 and 1/2 and 50 and 1/2.
And so that could be
construed as that way.
But you didn't pick it
randomly, and that sort
of human intuition,
to swap so I could
use that now to
design my strategy,
knowing that your random
numbers could be 50 and 1/2, OK?
No, I'll be 50-50
because what I'll
do, if I know that's
your strategy,
my numbers will be 1 and 2.
Well, when you do
these analyses,
you sort of, if it's declared
that's it, I can assume that.
And I might actually guess that.
In fact, that's why I did pick
two very small numbers and two
very big numbers.
But given the
perverse nature here,
when you saw the big
number, you got rid of it,
and when you saw the
small number, you kept it.
So you sort of did
reverse psychology
and it worked out, by chance,
that it worked out that.
Normally it would go
the other way, I think.
Of course, you've all
seen enough games now,
you know to do the
non-standard thing, I think.
Now, this kind of thinking
comes up all the time
in computer science algorithms.
You know, the
protocol that's used
to communicate across
a network, ethernet,
shared bus is randomized.
Each entity that wants to use
the bus flips a random number,
flips a random coin.
You could think of it that way.
And it broadcasts
with that probability.
And if there's a
collision, it backs off
and chooses a smaller
probability next time.
And if it gets through, then it
tries to cram a bunch of stuff
through, until you
get a collision again.
The best algorithms for
sorting a list of numbers
are randomized, quick sort,
which you'll see in 6046,
is a randomized algorithm.
In fact, it's not dissimilar.
You guess a random value
and split all the numbers
based on the random value.
Who's bigger, who's smaller,
and then you [INAUDIBLE].
You do things like that.
OK, that's all I'm going to say
about uniform distributions.
Next I want to talk about
the binomial distribution.
And this is the most
important distribution
in computer science, and
probably the most important
in all of discrete
calculations in the sciences.
In continuous distributions,
you get the normal distribution.
But, for discrete problems, the
binomial is the most important.
And there's two versions.
There's the unbiased
binomial distribution
and then there's the biased one.
Now this one's a little
more complicated.
You've got a parameter n again,
and the distribution function
on k, probability
of getting k is
n choose k times
2 to the minus n.
And n is at least 1, and
k is between 0 and n.
And then for the general
binomial distribution,
we have fn of k, the
probability of getting
k is n choose k times--
actually, it's fnp,
there's another
parameter p here.
p to the k times 1 minus
p to the n minus k power.
And p is a value between
0 to 1 typically.
It's a probability of
something happening.
So in the general
case, you've got nnp.
The unbiased case
corresponds to when p is 1/2.
Because if p is 1/2, you get 2
to the minus k and 2 the minus
n minus k, and that's
just 2 to the minus n.
So you can think of this
as the case when p is 1/2.
All right, to give
you an example why
this is so important, why
it comes up all the time.
Imagine that you've got a
system with n components.
And that each component
fails with probability p.
And you want to know the
probability of having
some number of failures.
So for example,
there's n components
and each fails independently--
in fact, mutually
independently--
with probability p.
And p will be between 0 and 1.
And now we're interested
in the number of failures,
so we'll make R be a
random variable that
tells us the number
of failed components.
And it turns out
the answer is simply
that function, which
we'll prove is a theorem.
The probability that R equals k
is simply fnp of k [INAUDIBLE].
So the general
binomial distribution
gives you the distribution
on the number of failures
in a system with
n components where
they fail with probability p.
So let's prove that.
To do that, we're going to
construct our tree again.
It's a little big because
you've got n components.
But you look at the
first component,
and that can fail or not.
And it fails a probability p.
It's OK with
probability 1 minus p.
And you have the
second component.
It can fail or not.
Again p and 1 minus p.
And you keep on going until
you get to the nth component.
And that can fail or not, the
probability p or 1 minus p,
in general down here.
And now we look at all the
sample points out here.
And it's all length and
vectors of failure or not.
So the top sample point here
would be n good components.
All right, the next one would
be the first n minus 1 are good,
the last one failed.
All the way down
to the very bottom,
you can have all n fail.
All right, so how many sample
points are there in the sample
space with n components?
2 to the n, all right?
Because you've got n positions.
There's two choices
for each value there.
Now how many of
the sample points
have exactly k
failed components?
Out of the 2 to the
n, how many correspond
to k of the components fail?
n choose k-- now this
goes back to counting.
Remember the
binomial coefficient.
So there are n choose
k sample points have
k failed components.
All right, what's the
probability of a sample
point with k failed components?
Well, I took k branches
with a failure.
Each of those gives
me a p, p to the k.
And I took n minus k
branches with no failure.
Each one of those
multiplies by a 1 minus p.
So no matter how I
got my k failures,
the probability for a particular
sample point with k failures
is just that, because I had
p get factored in k times,
in the failures, 1
minus p get factored
in n minus k times
for the situations
where it worked out all right.
So I've got this
many sample points.
Each of them has probability
p to the k times 1
minus p n minus k.
Any questions about that,
why that's the case?
All right, so now I can
compute the probability
there are k failures.
The probability that
R equals k is simply n
choose k, number of sample
points times their probability,
since they're all the
same for k failures.
And that, of course,
is just the formula
for the general
binomial distribution.
So that equals fnp of k, which
is what we are trying to prove.
OK.
Any questions about that?
So that's why it's
important, because there's
a lot of situations where
you're interested in the number
of-- if you had n
possible things,
what's the chance
k of them happen?
And it's just given
by this formula.
Now you can calculate this,
but, if I just told you,
for example, maybe I'm looking
at n is 100 and even p is 1/2,
you know, what's the
probability that we'd
get 25-- say, what's
the probably if getting
50 failed components?
Or if I flip 100 coins
and they're fair.
So probability half
of getting a heads.
What's the chance I actually
get 50 heads in 100 coins?
Looking at that, it's not
so clear what the answer is.
In fact, let's test
intuition here, for this.
We're going to
take a little vote
to see how good you are
looking at that formula,
or what your intuition is about
the probability of getting
exactly 50 heads.
It could be between 1 and
1/2, a half and a tenth,
a tenth and a hundredth, a
hundredth and one thousandth,
a thousandth and a
millionth, and 0.
I want to know what's
the probability, when
you flip 100 mutually
independent coins,
you get exactly 50 heads?
How many people think
it's at least a half,
that you get half heads?
Nobody likes that.
How many people think it's
between a half and a tenth?
One vote.
A tenth and a hundredth?
More.
Doesn't it have to be
at least a hundredth?
That's sort of the
most likely outcome.
There's only-- how many think
a hundredth and a thousandth?
All right.
A thousandth and a millionth?
Whoa, so you've got
to believe it is not
likely to get exactly 50
heads when I flip 100 coins.
All right, well the
answer is actually
between a tenth and
a hundredth here.
It's about 8%.
And we're going to compute that.
But here's another one.
I flip 100 coins.
What's the probability of
getting at most 25 heads?
So here, doesn't have
to be exactly 25.
It could be 25, 24, 23, 22,
all the way down to no heads.
So a lot of chances, all right?
To get at most 25 heads.
How many people think it's here?
Some, yeah, you've
got a lot of chances.
How about here?
Yeah, OK.
What about between a
tenth and a hundredth?
One person, two people left.
Between a hundredth
and a thousandth?
Nobody left?
Anybody here?
Thousandth and a millionth?
One person is left,
less than a million.
1 in a million?
There's the contrarian.
And you're right, the chance
of getting 25 or less heads
is less than 1 in a million.
So if somebody does it, his
name better be Persi Diaconis.
To get it consistently to 70,
[INAUDIBLE] 25 or fewer heads.
You get 75 tails or more is
extremely unlikely, all right?
So to see why that's
the case, we've
got to do a little
work on this formula.
Because we're saying that if
we sum this up for k ending 100
and k being 0 to 25,
and p being a half,
it's an incredibly tiny number.
So let's see why that is.
And this phenomenon
is course going
to be important in
computer science
because it's going to enable
you to tell almost exactly how
many components are going
to fail in a system,
if they're mutually independent.
All right, now I'm not going
to drag you through the math.
It's bad enough I'm going
to write it on the board.
There's a bunch of
this in the text.
And instead of k, I'm going to
represent by a parameter alpha
times n to be the integer k.
All right, this will replace
k with a new parameter alpha.
It's at most, and also it's
asymptotically equivalent
using tilde-- both of those are
true-- to this nasty looking
expression, 2 to the
alpha log p over alpha
plus 1 minus alpha log 1 minus
p over 1 minus alpha times
and n-- that's a big number,
it's 100-- over square root 2
pi alpha 1 minus alpha n.
And this, of course,
alpha is between 0 and 1.
Now when you do the
derivative on this thing,
it turns out its maximum
value is when alpha equals p.
And when you have alpha equals
p, you get log of 1 is 0,
log of 1 is 0.
All this messy stuff goes
away and we just get that.
And so in that case, fnp
of pn is at most, and also
asymptotically equal to 1 over
square root 2 pi p 1 minus p n.
And now you can plug in
values and compute things.
For example, if
I flip 100 coins,
and I want to know the
probability of getting 50--
that means alpha's a
half, and they're fair,
which means p is a
half, the answer is 8%.
So n equals 100 coins,
p is a half, then
the probability of 50 heads.
I just plug in p is a half here,
I get 1 over square root 50 pi,
which equals 0.080 and so forth.
So there's an 8% chance of
getting exactly 50 heads.
Now let's look at
the probability
of getting 25 or fewer.
And we'll see why that
is so surprisingly small.
OK, so for n equal
100 and p equal
a half an alpha equal a quarter,
because we want 25 heads,
I'll get exactly 25 heads first.
Probability of 25
heads is at most,
well that square root thing
comes out to about 0.09.
Then I get 2 to something.
I get 2 to the minus, all those
logs come out the 0.1887 times
n, which is the
kicker, that's 100.
So I get a 2 to the
minus 18th here.
And that makes this
thing be smaller than
or equal about to 1.913
times 10 to the minus 7.
So about 1 in 5 million.
The reason this gets
so small is because you
get the n in that
exponent up there.
And of course, this
is all computed
using Stirling's formula,
if you actually want
to go through the calculations.
You go start with n choose
k, which is your n factorial,
times over k factorial
n minus k factorial.
Plug in Stirling's formula and
you do a bunch of messy stuff,
and these things pop out.
And so it gets exponentially
small, exponentially fast.
In fact, if you were
to plot this thing,
if you plot the binomial
distribution function,
it looks something like this.
All right, so I have
0 to n, and then I
have pn, which is the maximum.
Here's the probability.
It goes 0 to 1.
And your maximum value is here
at 8% in the case of 100 coins,
and it just zooms down
exponential small.
You can't even draw because
it gets so small so fast.
This height here is
about 1 over root n.
And this width here of
the hump, is about root n.
And these things zoom down
to 0, exponentially fast.
And so that's what the binomial
distribution looks like.
And so it says that you are very
likely to be very close to pn
heads, or pn things happening.
And I won't go through the
math now-- probably do it
in recitation
tomorrow-- of computing
at most 25 heads, which is
the cumulative distribution
function.
And this comes up in
all sorts of places.
Like you have a noisy
communications channel,
and every bit as
dropped with 1% chance.
If you have 10,000
bits, you'd like
to know, what's the
probability I lost 2% of them
when I have 1% failure rate?
The chance of losing
2% out of 10,000
is like 2 to the minus 60 if
they're mutually independent.
So no chance of losing 2%.
All right, very good.
We'll do more this in
recitation tomorrow.